but you that way you and I got to sit
there and watch it and then you said
something very interested in me you go
how come you don't do jokes about like
you know real stuff like a bomb yeah
yeah you said about like you know I know
how you feel about corporations or your
politics things that you feel about like
stuff that'll change the world because
I'm more like kind of more
meat-and-potatoes about my stand-up and
I really went oh yeah but then I don't
know how to do that yeah I I don't think
I know how do we remember well
yeah but since I started working in the
store well I realized that you know
there's this you know you got to make
people laugh first oh well I'm good I
mean if you're gonna be this comedian
that I kind of I kind of aspire to be
which is like saying something you know
important or I don't know sane like like
telling people like this is what's
really going on it still has to be so
funny
you know it can't be too heavy-handed
but could I just say it's something
about you is I feel like I don't know
this for sure but I feel like you
avoided the clubs for a while and now
that you're playing the store which is a
kind of a newer environment yeah because
the quality of comedy I don't know if
it's less or more or whatever but it's
different it's good it's good it's
pretty good at the store but it's solid
you have regular people buying tickets
yes it's a different kind of crowd yes
and I feel like I've been mr.
alternative you know I mean I didn't
want to see that word yeah but you you
are a cool comedian yeah
but the Comedy Store has been very good
for me because of that because I've had
to like really look at just making jokes
like seriously and this isn't to kiss
your ass but when I'm following you I'm
like I'm in the back going oh my god
because you get such big laughs and
they're such well constructed jokes and
I just go up there kind of going what
did what is going on are you [ __ ] you
like I did say Bing Bing Bing and I'm
like going oh my god I'm gonna roll he
but I'd rather what have what you have
you know what you want is that true I'll
be real what do I because when you go up
the comedians come in to watch you I've
literally sat next to all of them real
watch you when I go up and I don't take
this offense but everyone leaves I'm
being only think that's because they've
seen you there for many it doesn't
matter
they just they've always left they won't
they just leave about it also see it can
be jealous no I see industry they're
like they go these producers are here
for this and they're here to see the guy
after you so I just make the assumption
I go I don't see my act right and they
do and as soon as I walk up I can see
them get up Tim Tim Thomas HBO we're
going in the hall we'll be back for the
next act though yeah we're definitely
we're they gonna kick a [ __ ] now it's
our [ __ ] break I'm pretty much the [ __ ]
break for comedians or people in the
industry I've never been to Montreal
[ __ ] I just said it is that true
yeah
that's insane yeah I'm pissed off I'm
not there this year but how many times
have you gone no only only three times
hurts that's it
it does it shouldn't it does because
other guys have been there i times you
know what I'm saying is is that but
that's you have credibility in the
comedy industry and it makes me feel
like that I don't
yeah this is so funny to me this is a
classic case of like insecure community
like like because I look at you and I'm
like it's [ __ ] gets movie and us
up for a second okay let me just say
this right now okay I just said I've
never been there
to Montreal the embedded blows that
blows my mind
are you get once we were rapping you
really yeah and they ever get you to
Montreal well the you because I want to
go to Montreal to them yeah they go you
know what is a pure set so they aired
over and over again you don't want to go
we try to make me feel like I don't want
to go Concepcion you know how they do
they they twist it you don't want to go
you know what are they telling you buddy
they air it over and over you mean it's
not gonna be good they tape you're sad
and they're in Canada you don't get a
lot of money from it right so and all
the industry people already know who you
are what's the point right but for me
it's just about being a part of the club
being up yeah
thank you that's a big thank you so much
baby he's been crying about this for
four years four years well that's a big
I never went to Aspen
meaning what's an aspen they used to
have a comedy class mother oh they used
to yeah and I was so pissed at that I've
always been an outsider how about really
yeah I don't think you have it there's
such a coolness and being an outsider I
think that Bobby's always wanted to be
an outsider as well you a guy right yeah
that's inside how is that inside that's
[ __ ] work Network yeah I know but the
thing is is that when you're in the
inside you realize that that's not
really the inside the only the lobby
area all the outsides actually the end
because it's bit I used to when it first
came on I loved it mm-hmm I was like
[ __ ] this this is exciting and it slowly
died to the point of now where you ever
hear that expression of course you have
beating a dead horse yeah they they have
taken the horse and fried it and made it
in mean it doesn't work it hasn't worked
for years because what they do is they
have I think MADtv did this a little bit
too it's like here's a character here's
a character here's her um al Sharpton
they never
blended yeah yeah anything good they
don't have a vision for this just sound
pretentious but they don't have a vision
for the show yeah it's just like I'm I'm
the mayor of right you know they have
like little celebrity impersonations and
it's yeah most of the sketches suck yeah
I had a little bump with the election
and everything and it was like this
intense thing that they were doing this
political thing and Melissa McCarthy was
doing short she's not even a member that
Ken
Melissa McCartney's doing Shawn Spencer
and now it's gone it's gone already
yeah it's already [ __ ] God yeah it's
not a place for dissent right which it
could have been yeah but they still
didn't be on the air even when where I
was on mad though they were still
treated differently than us they had
they it was yeah because no because we
would here's what he would get off a mad
like each one of us we're done I did
eight years or whatever right and then
we had to get back in line right where
they got do not and like here's a movie
or you know whatever we were like oh I
have to do first to read so yeah I know
I hear you I can't believe that
yeah I believe it it's no I believe but
what did it what is it is that Lorne
Michaels pipeline it's that pipeline
right it's Broadway video it's a machine
yeah and you have been around for very
long coming I have nothing against him
well I do and yeah yeah I do [ __ ] them
you know III feel like that they're kind
of the worst thing for American comedy
you hear me Michaels
you never [ __ ] gave me
prick your product has been planned for
25 years you know what can I just say
something I just had a spiritual
experience just now just now yeah
because you don't you don't give a [ __ ]
well like I can't because I feel like if
I say certain things there are Greek
consequences right so I don't say them
right are you worried about consequences
well if I say let me just say something
okay I are we gonna give an example I
was on a show called it was a cartoon
with Seth Meyers called the awesomes
alright I was a character on it okay but
when I first got it Lauren goes because
it's Broadway video no he has to
audition and Seth Meyers is like no I
Alfred it to him right yeah and Lauren
Michaels goes no I want him to read
anyway so then I said I don't want to do
it I don't want to do it and then two
months later right a week before we
start doing it oh you mean even though
you said you don't want to do it they
said no but then two months later they
were like give it to him right so then I
get it and I was like grateful like
thank you you are yeah and they made you
grovel little yes he is what a power
trip that [ __ ] no I want him to read for
it yeah yeah instead of you know he's a
piece and I say that with all due
respect yeah so much respect yeah I mean
especially like eight years I was like a
sketch show right Seth called me and
said I want you on the [ __ ] thing
right and then he had to so you know he
has a lot of power so I came Meyers has
a lot of power no Lauren Michaels well I
know that right so I that's what I'm
saying is that what you just said is I
would like to say that but I just never
have said it by the way by you saying
that yeah you just said it hey my gosh
he's with me
Bobby Lee you know what
thanks to you I'm not gonna say that
he's not gonna say it but oh yeah go
[ __ ] yourself [ __ ] yourself buddy
he died
[Music]